-Performing "Russian Roulette"
from his new album,
"It's Only Me,"
give it up for Lil Baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Now I'm grown, I finally
got my...together ♪
♪ Told girl we'll take time
and we just stick together ♪
♪ Every time bro catch a bid,
we do that thing together ♪
♪ I know he got two phones,
but I still send a letter ♪
♪ 'Cause I know how that feel ♪
♪ Don't compare me
to no other rapper ♪
♪ I feel like my stuff real ♪
[indistinct]
♪ Before I got a deal,
it's love for sho' ♪
♪ But you done broke the code,
I don't know how to feel ♪
♪ Ain't told nobody no for real
since I got a mil ♪
♪ I'm tied in ♪
♪ Another bloody summer
in Atlanta then ♪
♪ Lost five friends ♪
♪ Mama told me
that water was cold ♪
♪ I'd still have dived in ♪
♪ Never let nobody take me out
this beef, we dine in ♪
♪ My [indistinct]
I pray to God to help him ♪
♪ I was in a dark spot,
but I came back ♪
♪ And I broke the knobs ♪
♪ Be pushin' my country boy
for a perfect nine ♪
♪ Run the charts ♪
♪ Don't need your common art ♪
♪ This is stuff
that I live for ♪
♪ And these fine people
that are...for me ♪
♪ Hundred racks for my kids ♪
♪ Ain't my fault
you don't got more ♪
♪ I got rich on my life story ♪
[indistinct]
♪ Came back
and got right to it ♪
♪ Never question my loyalty ♪
♪ If it's that deep,
then don't do it ♪
♪ [indistinct] my heart is
when I'm going through it ♪
♪ Through with that ♪
♪ Say I'm done,
but then I double back ♪
♪ Are you dumb? ♪
♪ You the one, and
I'm the cause of that ♪
♪ Firearm always on,
I be clutchin' that ♪
♪ Know I'm wrong, out here
playing Russian roulette ♪
♪ All my life I had to fight,
I feel like Mike ♪
♪ Shootouts every other week,
we had that ♪
♪ Women every other night,
I'm past that ♪
♪ I'mma always play my part,
give a...'bout no awards ♪
♪ And I still ain't drop
my hardest... ♪
♪ I'm tryna get on
some artist... ♪
♪ My mind stay
in rented apartments ♪
♪ My accountant say
I need to slow it down ♪
♪ On these Dior garments ♪
♪ Close my eyes and think
about where I come from ♪
♪ When I'm performing ♪
♪ I'm on top of every dime ♪
♪ I check my balance
every morning ♪
♪ I'm relaxing with a bath ♪
♪ When they be asking
can they join us ♪
♪ And my left wrist...
these bracelets 60-pointers ♪
♪ In the Maybachs back-to-back
on the South Side ♪
♪ It was me and Gunna ♪
[indistinct]
♪ No doubt about it,
they believe me ♪
♪ Won't let 'em down,
I promise ♪
♪ I really cried
when Marlo died ♪
♪ I feel it all in my stomach ♪
♪ On the same thing I been on ♪
♪ Ain't never switching
my formula ♪
♪ I don't care
when they made fun of me ♪
♪ Can't beef with
nobody under me ♪
♪ These little guys
should honor me ♪
♪ I'm way up on 'em, honestly ♪
♪ Four buildings
in the last month ♪
♪ I'm boostin' up my economy ♪
♪ 4 million,
that was this week ♪
♪ Which one of y'all
wanna come for me? ♪
♪ Yeah, through with that ♪
♪ Say I'm done,
but then I double back ♪
♪ Are you dumb? ♪
♪ You the one,
and I'm the cause of that ♪
♪ Firearm always on,
I be clutchin' that ♪
♪ Know I'm wrong, out here
playing Russian roulette ♪
♪ All my life I had to fight,
I feel like Mike ♪
♪ Shootouts every other week,
we had that ♪
♪ Women every other night,
I'm past that ♪
♪ I'mma always play my part ♪
♪ Give a...'bout no awards
and stuff ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]